if you spend too much time on social
media then you're probably aware of the
list that has been circulating for over
a week now the list of Legend the
mythical list of unknown Origins uh
nobody's certain where this list came
from or who exactly was pulled in order
to compile it or if it represents
anything but the opinion of some random
Twitter User it's most likely that last
option but even so the list has as they
say sparked a debate and given rise to a
plethora of hot takes it's also been the
subject of many news articles and news
reports like this one watch unacceptable
places to take a woman on a first date
going viral on the social media platform
X Formerly Known of course as Twitter
yeah it's leaving men stumped on where
else they should take the woman the
first six places are popular restaurant
franchise chains like Applebees chilies
I want my baby b Olive Garden and the
Cheesecake Factory okay first of all
Olive Garden yeah all you can eat bread
sticks salad soup I mean that's a value
Megan by the way producer who made the
this list is this just going viral is it
like on Reddit or something wa in okay
so women weigh in okay so includes you
know cheesecake Factor all those any
fast food chain also Buffalo Wild Wings
big that's a good time if there's a good
game on other places mentioned include
movies the gym a bar for drinks coffee
or ice cream dates and sporting events
pretty much these women listed
everything there is to do clubs and
hooka lounges also made the list it got
many men up in arms okay so that's the
story uh someone somewhere pulled some
women somewhere and came up with a list
that uh that these women say they do not
want to be taken on for a first date and
that list is topped by The Cheesecake
Factory it also includes Applebees
chilies Chipotle Olive Garden the movies
Buffalo Wild Wings Red Lobster Waffle
House fast food the gym bowling buffets
nightclubs hook hookah bar sporting
events coffee shops basically you should
not take a woman to any known location
on Earth on a first date that's what was
decided by whoever decided it and we
we'll move past the fact that this list
is meaningless so that we can
participate in this conversation or I
should say not participate in it but
deliver the definitive answer to it so
that everyone can officially move on um
and let's begin with what the list gets
right because it does get some things
right and I think we should acknowledge
that and it's important for for young
men especially to know this uh you know
in in the dating scene and they're
planning a first date uh there are a few
items on that list that you you should
probably that that's true you don't want
to take your your date to one of those
places so it's true that fast food
places are probably a little too far on
the Casual side for a first date they're
also at this point incredibly depressing
dining experiences like I actually went
and this is true I went
inside um a Wendy's somewhat recently
because the drive-thru was too long and
this was the first time I've even seen
one car in a Wendy's drive-thru in at
least 25 years and but there there was
more than one there was like three and I
said this is crazy so I went inside and
as soon as I walked in the building I
just i l lost my appetite and then my
will to live it dreary dirty depressing
the employees scowling at you like
they're shocked that you came in also
like you don't know why you're walking
into a Wendy's they don't know why
you're here and they don't want you
there people are sitting by themselves
at tables and Corners like un unlit
Corners eating stale fries and weeping
quietly to themselves it was horrendous
now I still ordered my food and ate all
of it but uh I wasn't happy about it and
the point is that you don't want to
bring a date into that kind of
environment until you know that your
relationship is strong enough to stare
into the bowels of total hopelessness
and despair and survive and you don't
want to do that on a first date a
similar issue with Waffle House which um
isn't a great first date location unless
unless you're sure that your date loves
both waffles and bare knuckle street
fights and if she does then it's
basically dinner and a show the whole
thing costs less than 25 bucks that's a
good deal I'm also going to rule out
Chipotle for a first date because first
impression are extremely important and
you don't want her first impression of
you or yours of her to include explosive
diarrhea and speaking of First
Impressions all agree that
buffets actually may be problematic on a
first date only because it's too early
in the relationship for her to witness
you just like Crush six full plates at
Golden Corell um my my wife did I
remember this
distinctly my wife did not see me get to
work on a buffet until at least like a
few months into our relationship and and
I just and I and I annihilated that
buffet and she she was Gob smacked but
by that point she already knew that I
was a gluttonous slob so I was kind of
you know I was in a safe space I was
safe to let loose most of the rest of
the places on that list though don't
deserve to be on the list at all they
make excellent choices for First Dates
coffee shops and ice cream places these
are classic Options Bowling is always
fun bowling is the kind of thing that
everyone has an absolute blast doing
once every three years and the great
thing about bowling or something like
mini golf as well is that it gives you a
fun activity to do but still enables you
to talk to each other wh while helping
to smooth over any otherwise awkward
pauses and conversation it also allows
the man to show off his skills a little
bit and I know you think that I'm joking
about that well why does a woman care if
you're good at bowling but it's just
being good at something is attractive
tool even bowling now the only caveat is
that and this is kind of this is kind of
tricky
with bowling you don't want to be too
good at bowling so The Sweet Spot is to
bowl somewhere around a60 170 on the on
the upper uh range of it you don't want
to get over the 200 mark because you
want to look like you're naturally
talented at things but you don't want to
look like you're so good at bowling
because you actually take it seriously
and go bowling once a week as for chain
restaurants there should be no
hesitation there at all yet for some
reason chain restaurants have been
catching Strays all over the place
recently so just two weeks ago there was
a viral video of a woman refusing to get
out of the car on a first date because
she was so offended that the man had
taken her to the Cheesecake Factory
watch let me just get the door for you
okay he got me at the Cheesecake Factory
y'all I Ain you're not this
far
yes uh would you want me to open the
door for
you look at look are you you're
recording me
yeah yeah this is the Cheesecake
Factory this is the Cheesecake Factory
y'all what's the problem with that this
is a chain restaurant who takes someone
that looks like this to a chain
restaurant uh now first of all the
Cheesecake Factory is perfectly
respectable it's also expensive for a
chain restaurant two Entre an appetizer
and a couple of drinks will easily set
you back 80 or 90 bucks before tip and
that is a sizable Financial investment
in a date with someone you hardly know
you know the Cheesecake Factory I kind
of look at it as the economy plus of
chain restaurants I'm not saying it's
first class but it's not a middle seat
and Coach either I spent all of my
childhood and a good portion of my adult
life thinking of the Cheesecake Factory
as a nice fancy type place it's the type
of place you go if you want to splurge a
bit the first time I ever went to the
Cheesecake I I never even went when I
was a kid because when I was a kid my
The Cheesecake Factory was way outside
of where we were ever going to go if we
were going out to eat as a family and
that was like if I had suggested that I
would they would my parents would have
laughed at me like Cheesecake Factory
what do you think we're millionaires so
the first time I ever went I was an
adult and and and and I wore khakis to
The Cheesecake Factory because I thought
this is a fancy place now the second
time I wore jeans cuz I realized it's
not worth all that but still the point
is that uh no woman should be turning up
her nose at a place like that Grand
Canyon University is an affordable
private Christian University based in
Phoenix Arizona they're dedicated to
making education fit into your already
busy schedule which is why they offer
270 of their academic programs on line
from scholarships to academic support
gcu's graduation team provides you with
the personal support you need to obtain
your goals gcu's online programs offer
you the freedom to earn your degree on
your own time from wherever you are GCU
is praise for its culture of community
giving an impact they integrate the free
market system and a welcoming Christian
worldview into all of their academic
programs achieve your goals with a
personalized plan and a supportive team
behind you find your purpose at Grand
Canyon University private Christian
affordable visit gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
I know it's trendy to hate on chain
restaurants these days but these are
affordable and accessible establish
lishments and if as a woman you expect a
man to take you somewhere less
accessible and less affordable when he
doesn't even know you yet that tells me
that your priorities are wildly out of
balance it tells me that your priority
is to have your ego fed which means that
you are not the kind of woman a man
should be taking out in the first place
as I've said before if you expect a man
to pay for you on a first date and and
you know treat you on a first date
that's fine I paid for my wife on our
first date even though when we met way
back then she was is actually making
more money than me but uh but I paid on
the first date and because I believe in
Chivalry and and I'm an old-fashioned
kind of guy but those expectations on
your part as the woman come with
expectations of their own so if you want
the man to abide by traditional codes of
chivalry then you must abide by
traditional codes of Womanhood you must
be a sweet feminine conservative woman
you certainly must not describe yourself
as a feminist you cannot dip your toe in
gender roles only when you think you'll
get a free meal out of it that makes you
a hypocrite and a panhandler if you want
to be an old-fashioned lady when the
check comes you better be an
oldfashioned lady the rest of the time
but even if you are uh playing your part
you cannot demand that a man spend Top
Dollar on you before he even knows you
it's not reasonable to expect a man to
invest a day's pay or more into a
restaurant tab for the sake of a woman
who for all he knows because he doesn't
know you yet could be low quality and
low character and ironically a woman who
expects that kind of money to be spent
on her by some man she doesn't know has
only revealed herself to be exactly the
kind of woman who is undeserving of it
now I will admit that I did not exactly
practice what I preach in this regard
for the first date uh with my
wife back uh uh centuries ago I spent
multiple days pay on tickets to a fancy
dinner theater um now but she didn't
know how much the tickets cost or how
little I could afford them and would
have furiously objected had she known
and but here's the other thing it was
also a risky strategy on my part because
there another reason why I wouldn't
recommend it normally even though it
worked out great for me but I could not
come close to maintaining at that level
for the rest of our dating relationship
like that was the best date we would
ever go on until we got married because
that I couldn't possibly afford to do
that more than once and um from then on
it was Applebee's and Applebee's was
about as high class as it got and she
was fine with that she's still fine with
Applebees so you know I ended up with
The Best of Both Worlds which is what
you want a woman who knows how to carry
herself in a festar fine dining
establishment but who's perfectly happy
and at home in an Applebee's and in fact
these days if there's any Applebee's
slander happening in our house it's
usually coming from me I'm ashamed to
admit in any case the point is that a a
first date is about beginning the
process of getting to know each other or
figuring each other out you don't need
to spend a lot of money to do that a
bowling alley is a great place to start
that process or a Chili's if the night
gets really wild maybe you do both there
are enough hurdles that stand in your
way as a single person in the modern
dating scene there's no reason to add
more and unnecessary obstacles by being
snobby and high
maintenance and that is why the women
responsible for this list if those women
even exist are today
canceled if You' like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire or by going to the
Matt wallow Twitter page hope to see you
there God speed